let me call your mind
degree told Angela
I know it's Haram but we are going to
get married so you're in a Haram
relationship and you think you're going
to repent tomorrow and maybe marry them
tomorrow but we promised you tomorrow
repent today before you die tomorrow
I'm not his girlfriend I'm his wifey so
you're good enough to be his girlfriend
but not good enough to be his wife but
kind of my business
he'll never leave me I'll never leave
you I'll be there forever I'm gonna
marry you trust me the only boyfriend
that's not leaving these guys over here
I'm out we will live happily ever after
most of the times you're left
heartbroken depressed or suicidal I
trust him with my pictures and videos so
he's got pictures and videos of you and
he says he's not gonna share them but
that's none of my business
in her own relationship but we won't
commit Zinner hello so you're strong
enough to control your desires bro 90%
of our are looser couples and
documentation alone
what if his sister had a boyfriend hello
yeah but I told you to tell him that I'm
her boyfriend
okay they know that I'm her boyfriend
she hold her hold her there's somebody
on the line one second yeah but we
saying okay watch my sister's got a
boyfriend what she's gonna have a
boyfriend
you're disobeying Allah and His
Messenger but he loves me
he'll never cheat so he said he'll never
cheat on you
yeah yeah but that's none of my business
I'll have one tea please and my
boyfriend doesn't sleep around half of
STDs confirm he was younger 15 to 24
every single year 500 million people
catch STDs 65 litre diseases how do you
know your boyfriend or girlfriend
doesn't have one
shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot
shoot shoot shoot shoot